well one of the main themes I have in
Only the Strong is that the decline
sensed by so many Americans is not an
accident it's decline by Design
the left has had a plot to sabotage
American power going back 100 years you
see that in so many facets of their
actions again look at what they've done
to weaken the military
it's almost like birds migrating south
of the winter every time a Democrat
takes office he cuts the defense budget
they've also begun to distract the
military from its core Mission which is
preparing for and winning wars using all
kinds of critical race Theory uh
indoctrination or gender ideology
obsessions as opposed to focusing on war
fighting or take a look at what they've
done to energy production in America
energy is vital to our way of life it
literally Powers our economy and we're
the world's energy superpower when it
comes to oil and gas and coal yet Joe
Biden and the Democrats have promised to
eliminate fossil fuel production in
America not curb it not make it cleaner
but to eliminate it at the same time
they're dedicated to so-called green or
clean technology who's the world's
superpower when it comes to so-called
Green Technology China I mean they may
March under the banner of climate change
but the progressives Banner looks a lot
like China's five-star flag these are
not accidents these are things that they
have done on purpose
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
senator from the great state of Arkansas
as well as author of the new book Only
the Strong reserving the left's plot to
sabotage American power I think you
nailed it with the title Senator Tom
Cotton welcome to the Reuben report hey
Dave thanks for having me on it's a real
pleasure and I look forward to talking
to you about I want to be strong today
well I've wanted to talk to you for
quite some time and basically this book
is a layout of an awful lot of the
history of the lunacy that I've been
fighting against on this show so first
off what what caused you to write this
book I mean you're a senator you're
you're fighting the madness in DC all
the time what made you say hey I want to
go back and and look at where some of
this came from and and where it's going
well David all started last year in the
aftermath of the Afghanistan Fiasco
um at first I was astonished at Joe
Biden's bumbling then my team and I
spent a couple weeks in August trying to
do everything we could to get our
kansans and other Americans out of
Afghanistan but as we reflected on it in
the days after our departure from
Afghanistan I had so many people ask how
could this happen how could we lose to a
medieval band of savages but it also
went deeper to that to things they had
seen in recent years Bill and writers
rampaging in our streets and tearing
down statues of Our Heroes trying to
defund the police and at least attacking
the police when they couldn't defund
them as somehow illegitimate Calling
America systemically racist and
oppressive which led to a crime wave all
across our country America being a
laughing stock at the hands of our
adversaries around the world and at the
bottom of all those questions I thought
was how did it get to this point why
doesn't America win anymore and I wanted
to lay out for my readers exactly how
the left in America has for over 100
years plotted to sabotage American power
now I'm not claiming that liberals and
Democrats are necessarily
Un-American or they hate our country
although plenty are and plenty do but at
best they're ambivalent about America
their anguished about our past and
uncertain about our future and that's
why they've taken the steps over the
last hundred years they have taken to
weaken our military to entangle us in a
network of globalist international
institutions to bring American sources
of energy offline while we make
ourselves more dependent on China all
these steps are part of their effort to
make America just another country a more
normal place that doesn't view itself as
exceptional or special or that has any
special role attributed to it by God and
by our Founders and I wanted to lay out
that case in Only the Strong as well as
a road map of the future
so before we dive too much into the
specifics and everything that you just
said there is exactly what the book is
about since you mentioned Afghanistan
and that was sort of the Genesis of why
you decided to do this can you talk a
little bit of what it was like to be a
senator the few days before when it's
when the withdrawal is happening and
then after like how much information did
you have did you guys try to push back
on on the withdrawal at least how it was
done perhaps and just were you just
ignored or was were there any other
plans laid out that wouldn't have been
as messy as what we all saw
um yes a lot of us did try to explain
that what we saw in August was likely to
happen we didn't necessarily predict the
exact timing or fashion but the reason
why uh Donald Trump never withdrew from
Afghanistan in four years despite the
fact that he obviously wanted to was
because he was worried that it would
lead to a collapse of the Afghan
government and a return of the Taliban
to power which would imperil America's
interest and threaten Americans here and
abroad but Joe Biden came into office
and he said to hell with all that
remember in 2009 as I lay out in Only
the Strong he had insisted then on
cutting and running immediately and as
Barack Obama's own Secretary of Defense
Bob Gates said he subjected President
Obama to something like Chinese water
torture when everyone else was trying to
get Barack Obama off the dime to make a
decision on Afghanistan to commit the
troops necessary to achieve the strategy
he himself had proclaimed in the 2008
campaign Joe Biden kept nattering in his
ear ceding mistrust with our military
saying this Mission could never be
accomplished and he carried a chip on
his shoulder for 12 years that Barack
Obama didn't listen to him and I think
he got into office in 2021 and his toxic
combination of incompetence and
insecurity led him to want to think want
to prove that he had been right all
along that Barack Obama and the generals
and all of those Republicans and
Democrats who had criticized him for 12
years were wrong so in April 2021 when
he said we're going to rip the Band-Aid
off does it matter if Taliban has to
filled the conditions that President
Trump uh set for them in the withdrawal
agreement from 2020 we're just going to
get out and most perversely of all said
we're going to get out by 9 11 as if
that were somehow a great way to honor
the sacrifices and the losses that we
suffer in that day and in everyday since
then and as time passed from April to
August it was clear to me partly based
on public reports partly based on the
intelligence we're receiving that
president President Biden had not taken
the steps necessary to get all Americans
out to get their family members out to
get out green card holders to get out
the loyal Afghans who'd served alongside
us and they were trending towards a
disaster and when people ask me how did
we see the scenes from August 2021 where
Afghans were running under the tarmac
they were jumping on the aircraft uh
Wheels trying to fly out of the country
they're handing babies over the uh
barbed wire topped walls of the Airfield
it's Joe Biden's rank
incompetence that caused all that we
knew this was coming he was warned that
it was coming he was Warner by members
of his own Administration worn by senior
military officials and he simply did not
listen to them in fact just five weeks
before the fall of Afghanistan he was
saying there was no way we would see a
scene like we saw in Saigon in 1975
which had to shamefully take off from
our Embassy in helicopters that's
exactly what we saw and it was because
of Joe Biden's weakness
what do you think a clean effective
withdrawal would have looked like so for
those of us that you know it was the
longest war in American history in
essence over over 20 years it was
unclear to a lot of people why we were
there at this point certainly my more
libertarian side thought we shouldn't
have even be been there in the first
place but at some point if you're going
to wrap these things up it seems like it
always is going to be somewhat messy
what do you think a a decent withdrawal
actually would have looked like well
Dave first I want to go back to the
beginning of the Afghan war which was
almost universally supported in the
Congress by the American people since
that's the land from which Osama Bin
Laden and Al Qaeda had attacked us
having been given Safe Harbor where
that's Taliban there's no question that
we took a lot of twists and turns in
Afghanistan as we did in Iraq that we
shouldn't have taken our main interest
in Afghanistan was to ensure that it
couldn't be used as a training ground
and launching pad for further attacks
our interest there was not try to try to
remake Afghan culture it wasn't try to
improve literacy or bring Economic
Development all those are good things
for the Afghan people certainly but it's
not in America's core interest that
those things happen so there are many
points along the way when we should have
taken stock and said we're no longer
serving our Vital national interests
here one was in 2009 and then again in
2011 Barack Obama announced a new
strategy but telegraphy wasn't committed
to it I'd been there right before that
announcement I'd heard a lot from
Afghans uh about their traditional
proverb you have the watches but we have
the time unfortunately that proved to be
right what a final departure from
Afghanistan could have looked like and
probably should have looked like under
the circumstances that President Trump
and later President Biden inherited was
ensuring that there was enough Technical
and logistical support to the Afghan
Army to make sure it didn't collapse as
I write in Only the Strong President
Biden didn't just withdraw our troops he
withdrew the Western mechanics and
contractors that kept the Afghan Air
Force flying these kinds of troops or
even these kind of civilian contractors
they're not not Frontline trigger
pullers they're not door kickers they're
not going on waves against the Taliban
but their president presence did give
the Afghan Army a lot of moral support a
lot of material support that would have
allowed them perhaps to maintain
conditions across the country that would
have forced the Taliban to negotiate
some kind of political outcome as
opposed to enable the Taliban to seize
the entire country in a span of just a
few weeks last summer do you know if
Biden had anyone in his I mean look he's
probably not going to listen to Tom
Cotton but do you know if he had anyone
in his ear in the administration that
was going Hey Joe this thing is not
going to go as planned we're going to
get horrific images they're going to
take all our weapons etc etc he did
almost everyone frankly uh certainly his
uniform military leaders but also a lot
of his fellow Democrats the people he
appointed to high positions uh look they
wanted to get out of Afghanistan just
like Donald Trump just like Barack Obama
for him but they also knew the dangerous
consequences that would follow if we did
what Joe Biden did just simply pull up
Stakes without any plan to keep the
country and the government stable there
and it's not just Afghanistan you saw
within weeks of the withdrawal from
Afghanistan Vladimir Putin beginning to
Marshal troops on the border of Ukraine
there's a dangerous Afghan effect now
just like there was a dangerous Vietnam
syndrome after Vietnam that will
reverberate and harm our country's
interest at least as long as Joe Biden
is president
do you think that that Putin basically
that day was thinking all right this is
my move now because they'll have no
appetite for stopping me
oh there's no question uh I mean Joe
Biden spent his first year in office
appeasing Vladimir Putin enticing him
and tempting him to a trial of strength
to use Churchill's famous line that I
quote in Only the Strong you know when
he came into office he granted uh
extension of the only arms control
training we have left with Russia with
no concessions whatsoever something
Donald Trump refused to do that was the
first signal of weakness the second
signal of weakness was to allow the
Nordstrom to gas pipeline to go forward
again something that Donald Trump had
refused to do last April When Vladimir
Putin began to build up troops on
Ukraine's border for the first time Joe
Biden pleaded to have a fancy Summit in
Europe to elevate Vladimir Putin's
stature internationally when you combine
all those along with the Afghan effect I
think Vladimir Putin saw the window of
opportunity to achieve what he's always
wanted to achieve as I explained it not
only the strong which is to reassemble a
Russian Empire which starts in Ukraine I
think Joe Biden's weakness throughout 22
21 tempted Putin to go for the jugular
there and now we and especially
ukrainians are living with the
consequences of that weakness
you mentioned some of Biden's motives
and making up for some of the Obama
stuff that sort of thing
um how much of what's going on generally
speaking right now whether we're talking
about this withdrawal or the economy or
now Russia Ukraine et cetera et cetera
do you think is is intentions like
actually intended to to harm us which is
partly what you're talking about in the
book versus just complete mismanagement
and hiring of the wrong people
well one of the main themes I have and
Only the Strong is that the decline
sensed by so many Americans it's not an
accident it's decline by Design
the left has had a plot to sabotage
American power going back 100 years you
see that in so many facets of their
actions again look at what they've done
to weaken the military
it's almost like birds migrating south
of the winter every time a Democrat
takes office he cuts the defense budget
they've also begun to distract the
military from its core Mission which is
preparing for and winning wars using all
kinds of critical race Theory uh
indoctrination or gender ideology of
sessions as opposed to focusing on war
fighting or take a look at what they've
done to energy production in America
energy is vital to our way of life it
literally Powers our economy and we're
the world's energy superpower when it
comes to oil and gas and coal yet Joe
Biden and the Democrats have promised to
eliminate fossil fuel production in
America not curb it not make it cleaner
but to eliminate it at the same time
they're dedicated to so-called green or
clean technology who's the world's
superpower when it comes to so-called
Green Technology China I mean they may
March under the banner of climate change
but the progressives Banner looks a lot
like China's five-star flag these are
not accidents these are things that they
have done on purpose they want to have
five dollar a gallon gas they want a
military that is not capable of taking
the kind of assertive confident action
that Ronald Reagan for instance took
they want America to be enmeshed in a
globalist network of international
organizations and one-sided treaties
that's again to get back to one of the
main themes of Only the Strong they're
deeply ambivalent about American power
and America itself
so I want to get into that that hundred
year March that got us to all of this
one other thing on the international
front specifically uh since we've sort
of briefly discussed Russia and Ukraine
I mean do in effect are we at War right
now I know there's been no war declared
Congress isn't being called to discuss
it but at some point when you are
endlessly funding something when you are
training troops when you are sending
weapons I mean what are you and your
colleagues saying about this at this
point and should we be calling Congress
to to talk about this make some sort of
Declaration if that's what we're doing
and and what do you think Biden would do
about all that I mean the fact that
we're not even discussing that seems
rather bizarre to me
well the United States is not at War but
we are certainly supporting Ukraine and
its right to defend itself and its
territory and its homes it's regrettable
that we got to this point which we did
again because of Joe Biden's weakness in
2021 which tempted Vladimir Putin to do
exactly what he's always wanted to do
frankly what he did in 2014 as well the
first time he invaded Ukraine I have to
note as I do sometimes my Democratic
friends in the Senate which always
sticks in their crawl but Vladimir Putin
has a habit of invading Ukraine when
Democrats Are Presidents
somehow there was a four-year blip where
it didn't happen huh exactly uh but
we're not at War nor should we be at War
I for instance agree with the decision
that we're not going to commit American
troops to fight in Ukraine I disagree as
I write in Only the Strong that Joe
Biden should have announced that in
advance it's a bad thing in a contest of
Wills to keep telling your adversary
what you won't do it it screams
hesitancy and humidity and Extreme
Caution by contrast look at Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan almost his entire
presidency supported uh Afghan
guerrillas against Soviet Russia he
never considered putting American troops
on the ground in Afghanistan but he also
didn't rule it out publicly he frankly
didn't say much at all publicly about
our efforts in Afghanistan against the
Soviets that's because he understood
that you don't want to simplify your
adversary's planning you want to keep
them on their toes you might make them
uncertain about what's going to happen
next so while we're not at war with
Ukraine or I'm sorry in Ukraine we are
standing by ukrainians who are simply
fighting for their primordial right to
defend their homes and their territory
and we have vital interests at stake
there not just in Europe but around the
world for instance imagine the signal it
would send to Xi Jinping in the Chinese
Communist if Western efforts in Ukraine
falters after just eight or nine nine
months I think you could expect them to
go for the jugular in Taiwan very soon
after it just like Vladimir Putin did
after he saw Joe Biden's weakness in
Afghanistan last summer I said I was
going to only ask you one more on the
international thing but just extending
that real quick I I've had Senator Rand
Paul on a few times and you know one of
his big things is hey if we're going to
give them this money which I know he's
not thrilled about in the first place
but if we're going to do it can we at
least get some receipts and basically no
there seems to be no receipts to any of
this what do we do about that I mean
because I think a lot of people when
they see that and they are another 10
billion here meanwhile Florida you know
is crushed with this hurricane and could
use some money or whatever it might be
or just give the people back their money
I find that that's one of the things
that people are really upset about that
we don't even know who we're giving the
money to
David I hear similar uh views at home
and across the country on the campaign
Trail I do think we can impose some
tighter controls on how this Aid is
being provided to Ukraine I expect a
republican Congress will I think we can
also demand that our European Partners
do more to support Ukraine as well now
much of our Aid that you read about in
the newspapers is the in-kind value of
the military transfers that we are
making a lot of that money in the end
gets spent here in the United States on
high paying jobs in our defense industry
some of our European Partners don't have
that kind of mature defense industry
they don't have that much many weapons
they can supply they should be stepping
forward and providing more of the direct
financial support to the government in
Ukraine so it cannot just support its
military on the front lines but it's
people as well but I do think that we
can have more accountability for what
has happened Ukraine and certainly what
will happen in the future and we can
demand a greater contribution from our
European allies
okay so let's back up to something that
you mentioned about the book earlier you
said about a hundred year March and you
know a lot of people when they ask me
Dave when did this crazy woke left this
Progressive thing happen you know people
talk about okay maybe in the 60s you
know more communist or socialist leaning
professors got into the universities and
that's really where it started but
you're really painting a picture that be
began beyond that Woodrow Wilson can you
get into some of the beginnings of this
sure Dave
um so not only the strong I explained
that much of modern left-wing thinking
goes back to the Progressive Era and
specifically Woodrow Wilson
um who is a professor of political
science before he became president you
know for the first 100 years or so of
American History both parties
consistently appealed to our Founders
they claimed that they were the one
carrying the true Banner of our founding
of the Declaration of Independence in
our constitution Woodrow Wilson was the
first politician to explicitly repudiate
our founding in terms that no politician
today would do I mean Democrats today uh
certainly will condemn certain aspects
of our founding but they always claim to
be living up to its truest calling not
Woodrow Wilson you can see in his
writings which were prolific as a
professor but he explicitly repudiated
the Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution uh he said that the
Declaration was outmoded it was fixed in
its own time that we all know that
people aren't created equal he said the
Constitution was too rigid he called it
Newtonian but it appealed to the law of
gravity it posted darwinian appealing to
the law of evolution and that it was
time that we'd be able to evolve our
system of government and our way of life
you know that's where the term in legal
thinking comes from the evolving or
living Constitution which really just
means the Constitution is dead because
the Constitution is supposed to be
permit and fixed based on our permanent
and fixed human nature and that's where
our Founders based their politics where
they base their foreign policy views as
well that man is a fallen and sinful
creature but we can still we can still
in the right kind of system built on the
right kind of moral principles achieve a
degree of freedom and safety and
prosperity heretofore unknown in the
world Woodrow Wilson and the
progressives rejected all of this this
is when you begin to get the
administrative state with which we're so
familiar today but it's really an
innovation only going back about a
hundred years when Woodrow Wilson was
president he started creating agencies
like the Federal Trade Commission now
you have this entire alphabet soup of
bureaucrats who are unelected yet they
presumed to write regulations for us
they presume to enforce them they
presume to adjudicate disputes involving
those regulations which James Madison
said and the Federalists is the very
definition of tyranny when you can uh
accumulate legislative executive and
judicial power in a single set of hands
so you don't get to the extreme
left-wing views the extreme
anti-American views that you mentioned
until the 1960s but it's not a very long
step from repudiating our Declaration of
Independence our Constitution and our
founding principles which happen with
Woodrow Wilson the progressives to
having outright rejection of America
itself as I lay on not only this strong
yeah do you think his his full intention
with the the Deep state or whatever you
want to call it but these bureaucrats
and these departments that live on
forever well past the people who founded
them that that really was in some ways
to subvert the Declaration of
Independence and Constitution meaning if
you could just staff these people of
these institutions with enough of your
own people then actually the founding
documents wouldn't matter that much yeah
there's no question about that and it's
not even my opinion or your opinion Dave
Woodrow Wilson wrote about this uh in
his essays and his books he spoke about
it and some of his speeches he believed
that our constitution with its systems
of federalism and separated powers and
checks and balances was outmoded for
modern times it couldn't move fast
enough it couldn't move enough detail
instead he envisioned a supposed a rule
by supposed nonpartisan neutral
scientific experts who can carefully
carefully distinguish all the competing
interests rise above those interests and
set the rules for our society According
to some abstract notion of right and
Justice as opposed to politics being a
system that recognizes our imperfect
nature
that recognizes that while man's Fallen
nature means the government has to be
able to control the government has to be
able to for instance to police crime and
ensure Civil Justice that those same
people are going to be running the
government itself the same people
running the government also are fallen
in sinful creatures therefore the
government has to be able to control
itself that's why we have things like
federalism while we have things like
separation of powers why we have things
most importantly like regular elections
all these things were Innovations at our
founding they may seem usual now but
their Innovations at our founding
Woodrow Wilson wanted to get beyond all
that he had this idea that there was
going to be this Elite cast of
scientific nonpartisan experts who would
help uh set the rules for our society
and you know maybe back then you could
have seen or you could have thought well
this needs to happen but after a hundred
years of experience with these
bureaucracies who thinks that's the case
anymore I mean Tony balchi may be the
perfect example to steal of Woodrow
Wilson's ideal of it of a neutral
nonpartisan scientific bureaucrat yeah
that's anything but what he has behaved
like over the last year or think about
Lois Lerner at the IRS and the Tea Party
controversies we're thinking about
Peter's stroke and Lisa Page at the FBI
trying to uh take down the Trump
presidency who really has faith that
these bureaucrats without any checks
without any balances without any
oversights are operating for the public
good as opposed to their own narrow
interest or the partisan interests of
the democratic party yeah it actually
sounds far more like a dystopian Philip
K dick novel than it does something that
a future president would would
eventually write when do you think the
Democrats as a party completely tipped
over into that because you know if you
think only you know 40 or 50 years 50
some odd years ago JFK as a Democrat
asked not what the country can do for
you ask what you can do for the country
is is very reverse of oh just bow to the
State all the time when do you think
they actually fully tipped into what we
now see with with the modern Democrats
you see it progressing steadily from
Wilson through FDR and Truman and then
getting to the 60s about JFK I write a
lot about Kennedy and Only the Strong
um no doubt uh he was capable of soaring
rhetoric but it masked a terrible record
um JFK very much subscribed to Woodrow
Wilson's conception of the
administrative State and technocratic
expertise he had all these so-called
best and brightest tinkering with the
economy most especially in the
Department of Defense tinkering there uh
disregarding the wisdom of the men who
had helped win World War II and as I
write in Only the Strong you see this
most importantly in Vietnam
JFK turned Vietnam into what was a local
conflict in which we had one side South
Vietnam that was capable of fighting and
defending itself with our support but
thanks to his weakness thanks to his
indecision thanks to his belief in his
kind of enlightened scientific tinkering
he and LBJ turned the Vietnam War into
an American war that whose Legacy has uh
um distorted the views of America and
turned so many left-wing Democrats
openly hostile against our country then
and since so is there any Democrat
that's left I mean when you're talking
to your colleagues in the Senate I mean
I was a Democrat for most of my life
most of my you know that that's what put
me on the map I was a Democrat I was a
lefty and I started you know seven or
eight years ago saying hey something's
not right here and then I kind of just
followed that path down the road and now
when I look at the Modern Democrats it's
like man there is nobody left that I
think would represent
perhaps a government that maybe would be
a little bigger than you want but not a
completely totalitarian government there
there seems like there's nobody left are
they secretly around I mean do you
privately meet with these people and
they go boy the squad's out of control
but I'm afraid of them yeah I wish I
could say I did Dave but no uh uh
Democrats like the squad members in the
house are fully in the saddle uh
responding in many cases to the large
activist base of the democratic party I
mean when you think about Democrats who
believe in a strong confident powerful
America the last one I can really think
of is Joe Lieberman and what happened to
him the Democrats voted him out in their
own Primary in 2006. uh people before
him who were somewhat anomalous like say
uh scoop Jackson
um but for a long time there just hasn't
been many strong Democrats now when it
comes time to go to the polls they
sometimes might like to present
themselves as strong or caring about
your concerns in the same way Democrats
have been making a lot of noise over the
last couple months worried about gas
prices but it's all at the side what
they're really worried about is their
own electoral future not about the
future of America
so if we Flash Forward this I know uh
nobody wants to be in the prediction
game especially a sitting Senator but if
we flash forward this to the midterms
that are you know basically in a week or
10 days at this point
I mean
do you sense this red wave that everyone
senses and and what do you think about
sort of the overconfidence feeling that
that you know you got to worry about
well I believe Republicans are going to
win control of the house and the Senate
I don't want to Hazard a guess of how
many seats we'll have but I think most
Americans now are looking
at where their lives are now versus
where they were two years ago they're
making less money they're spending more
money their streets are less safe we've
had five million illegal aliens enter
our country there's a major war in
Europe China now has a new uh an
aggressive dictator unlike anything that
they've had since now who's shooting
missiles over Taiwan I think they're
very worried about the future of our
country and they realize that again this
is not an accident this is not a mishap
it all goes directly to the Democratic
party's choices and in many cases their
intentional desire for instance see
higher gas prices and they want to check
and balance on Joe Biden yeah it's
incredible the the intentions part of it
I'm just so amazed by that they that
they actually say it in front of us you
know we want to end fossil fuels and
then we watch these prices go up and
then they say oh but the price going up
has nothing to do with us it's all
because of Putin you have to sort of
admire that because then the media runs
covered does that ever does it ever make
you jealous that they have a whole uh
mainstream media to run cover for them
that I would say does Run cover for guys
like you as much
well we have reality on our side I mean
look we had inflation uh while we had a
pandemic
and we had inflation before Vladimir
Putin invaded Ukraine it wasn't caused
by supply chain shortages brought on by
the coronavirus it wasn't because by
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine it
was caused by the Democrats spending
trillions of dollars we don't have and
as I explained not only the strong
Waging War on America's energy
production those are the two main
reasons we have record high inflation
and why so many American families
struggle to make their budgets meet at
the end of the month
so what would you want uh I almost said
Obama who might be pulling the spring
the strings what would you want Biden to
do today if if you sat down with him
today and said hey this energy crisis we
have to fix this what would you want him
to do right now well I'll write a little
bit about this and Only the Strong
because it can't be stressed enough that
that energy literally Powers America
that's why we call it the power the
power Zone oh the power's back on that's
what makes a difference in Modern Life
going back 250 years is the energy we
get from sources like coal oil gas and
now nuclear power as well we have to
recognize that those energy sources are
going to power America for the rest of
our lifetime it is a fantasy to think
that wind power and solar power is
somehow going to replace those sources I
mean we still get seven eight the ball
of our energy from fossil fuels and
nuclear power in America and even among
so-called renewable or clean energy we
get a lot more from water and wood and
crops than we do get from wind and solar
combined so as I write not only strong
we have to to reinvigorate the fossil
fuel industry in America now there's no
single thing that Democrats have done to
strangle fossil fuel production America
so there's no single thing we can do to
help unleash it but there's a lot of
steps we can take
for instance we can start building
critical infrastructure most importantly
new pipelines I was in Western
Pennsylvania a couple weeks ago with MIM
and Oz on the campaign Trail we visited
a natural gas pad there's enough natural
gas in Pennsylvania and Ohio and the
rest of America to essentially replace
all of the energy that we Import in this
country yet New England is paying
sometimes quadruple the rates for
natural gas this winter as the rest of
the country does why because New York
won't let let pipelines be built across
its territory to provide American Gas to
American citizens
think about the LNG liquefied natural
gas that we could export to other
countries wouldn't it be better if
Europe was relying on America for
American Gas rather than Russia for
Russian gas
look at the amount of Permitting that
has not occurred on federal lands which
is almost 30 percent of this entire
country to allow oil and gas exploration
or federal waters so there's a lot of
steps we can take to make sure that the
federal government is encouraging and
promoting energy production in this
country some of those are also simply
rhetorical or even economic you know
there are many left-wing banks on Wall
Street that are part of the Democrats
campaign against fossil fuels in America
we should be celebrating the fact that
we have
Roughnecks and coal miners who are
helping achieve energy Independence here
and providing energy to our allies
around the world we shouldn't be trying
to cut them off from access to the
credit and the equity markets if we take
those steps if Biden would simply
appeal to sanity when it comes to our
energy sources here in America we can
bring gas prices down we can bring your
electricity bills back down and we can
help rebuild American power around the
world as well yeah unfortunately I think
I can speak for everyone watching this
right now they're going they just know
he's not going to do it like it's just
not in the cards but speaking of energy
and pipelines and all of these things
do we have any sense of what happened to
Nordstrom I mean we basically just don't
talk about it you know these these I
think it was four explosions we just
don't know what's going on and we're
just letting it be
um
I probably shouldn't comment Dave on uh
what happened in the Nordstrom pipeline
I will say that it never should have
gotten that far in the first place
Donald Trump was right to try to stop it
before it got near conclusion and I'm
glad that it's not going to be brought
online uh this is something that
Democratic administrations before
President Trump should have stopped in
its infancy so it wasn't able to be used
as leverage against the West
got it all right let's uh let's shift a
little way from energy to to what it
seems to be driving the the progressives
of today which is the woke stuff the the
gender stuff the race stuff all of that
um I guess that doesn't surprise you
either like that was just going to be
the next sort of cultural extension of
the deep state in some sense or the
administrative state
it doesn't surprise me most alarming as
I write not only the strong is it's
seeping into our military as well
um this is done largely at the behest of
the civilian appointees at the
Department of Defense under Joe Biden
the idea that there's a sexist or racist
or extremist lurking around every corner
hiding behind a highly polished
increased veneer which is simply not the
case uh our military uh is exceptional
they recruit uh from a very select group
of young men and women uh you're much
safer uh and you're much more likely to
be judged on your merits in our military
than you are for instance as some
left-wing college campus in America
um that hasn't stopped down to the
lowest level an effort to indoctrinate
our troops with things like critical
race Theory or gender ideology I'll tell
you a story that I tell in Only the
Strong as an example A friend of mine
with whom I served recently became a
battalion Commander so he's in charge of
about 800 to a thousand troops
he has to ensure that his troops all go
through something called the healthy
sexuality briefing now this is a lot
more than what troops got back in World
War II about the threats of STD and
things like that this is all about
gender identity and transitioning and so
on and so forth
and he says that this is tracked all the
way up to the division headquarters and
presumably submitted to some higher
commands at the Department of Defense
so he says put yourself in the shoes of
one of my company commanders who's in
charge of about 125 of my of my troops
he knows that he's got some bureaucrat
up at higher headquarters looking over
his shoulder to ensure that there's a
little green check mark next to every
soldier's name on the healthy sexuality
briefing
he doesn't have that same bureaucrat
looking over his shoulder on things like
shoot move and communicate tactical
training at the squad level so what is
he going to take a risk on in his
quarterly training plan
is he going to take a risk on not
achieving 100 briefing on healthy
sexuality or is he going to take a risk
that not all of his troops will go
through the appropriate kind of tactical
training to have them ready to fight and
win on the battlefield I think the
question answers itself and now maybe
they won't go to war and maybe their
lives won't be put at risk because our
military prioritize the wrong things in
training but do we really want to gamble
our national security on that more to
the point do we want to gamble their
safety on it I suggest not all this can
end in a stroke but it takes a new
president a new secretary of defense to
put an end to it so is that is that what
it would take I mean literally so if we
got let's say a Republican president we
now have a different Secretary of
Defense I mean in essence you're saying
you you have to fire a tremendous amount
of the top brass at the military right
no I don't think that's necessary Dave
because I mean the military is different
from say the Department of Labor or the
Department of Health and Human Services
there is a chain of command and there's
an ethos uh of moving out when you've
received a lawful order
um and I think it would only take a new
president Republican president
Republican Secretary of Defense say all
this ends today so for instance Dave
when I was in the Army I frequently I
shouldn't say frequently once every six
months we had a lot of mandatory
briefings you normally set aside a
morning of training board and it was on
everything from equal opportunity
policies to motorcycle safety to
personal finances
and that briefing made clear albeit
shortly that the Army is an equal
opportunity organization it does not
tolerate any kind of harassment or
discrimination on the basis of race or
sex or religion or nationality or what
have you and that was that and I never
saw anything like that when I was in the
Army Dave
um all it takes is one Secretary of
Defense to say we're going back to the
old ways of reminding our troops that
this is an equal employment organization
equal opportunity organization and we
have zero tolerance for any kind of
harassment and discrimination here's one
PowerPoint slide that states that policy
a soldier will get briefed on that once
a year once every six months and if I
find out any command is using anything
other than this single statement of
policy that Commander will be removed
that will end the nonsense right there I
promise you because that's what most of
these commanders want to do you think my
friend my talent who just became a
battalion Commander who's achieving the
Pinnacle of his professional career
wants to spend his time on a healthy
sexuality briefing no the vast majority
of offers officers and Senior enlisted
troops want to focus on training their
troops being ready to fight a war they
don't want to have to focus on all these
distractions
when you're back home in Arkansas and
you're talking to constituents and
they're seeing all of this craziness
with the with the gender stuff and uh we
just covered it on my show where the
president is you know sitting at the
White House with the Trans uh journalist
who's you know and in essence he's
saying that the states shouldn't have
rights when it comes to whether these
procedures should go through I mean just
the Litany of crazy things I would
suspect in a place like Arkansas there
is there is very little tolerance for
this kind of thing
yeah Dave I've learned uh over the last
10 years what I kind of since growing up
is you can never underestimate the good
decent common sense of hard-working
arkansans and when they hear things like
kids being uh exposed to transgender
ideology and kindergarten or second
grade
of uh doctors performing double
mastectomies on healthy teenage girls or
using uh drugs to block normal pubescent
development in boys and girls they just
think it's insane our legislature has in
fact taken action to stop that kind of
abuse of children which I think any
decent civilized society should it's one
thing when someone becomes 18 years old
and as an adult and can make decisions
for themselves but just like we take a
lot of other steps to protect children
from fads and Fashions and from
irresponsible adults I think this is a
reasonable step that we take as well in
my state and hopefully a lot of other
states to protect young children
do you sense that the direction that
America is going in where the the states
are now feeling very very different than
each other uh I know you you're you
appreciate federalism so you know look I
I was in California it went off the deep
end I now live in Florida as I as I tell
everyone I feel like I live in a
different country actually but do you
think that this trend where the red
States seemingly will be more red the
blue States seemingly will be more blue
uh do you think there's a danger there
that we will have nothing that will
unite us at some point if we keep going
down that route
well Dave I think the real danger is
more of these liberal states and cities
trying to impose their views and their
values on the more conservative areas of
our country take California and Arkansas
as an example uh I love California it is
a beautiful state it's got a great
history it's got great people I don't
agree with much of the political turn
it's taken over the last 20 years
however it's lost a lot of great people
like you who want to get away from the
higher taxes and the regulation and the
lack of housing the high costs at the
same time I wouldn't presume to set the
laws for California from Arkansas I
wouldn't think that I I get a say or
that my fellow Arkansas get a say in
dictating what are traditional state and
local matters to a state like California
that's not the case the other way around
though you know California like other
states have tried to impose their views
and their values on other states
sometimes they even do things like
adopting travel Bans saying that
California officials can't travel to a
state like Texas or Arkansas unless of
course you're Gavin Newsom then you
should travel to places like Idaho and
Montana to go to your multi-million
dollar Resort lodges with your security
detail yeah but I think Federalism is
not just a way to protect our liberties
as our founding fathers understood it
it's also a way to account for the large
Continental Nation with a genuine kind
of diversity economic Geographic
historic diversity that allows people to
govern themselves in the ways best
suited to their environments you know
Maine for instance is going to have a
lot of interest a lot of focus on the
lobster trade not exactly something we
spend a lot of time on in Arkansas right
but then again Arkansas is a very large
Forester industry you know not against
something that you see in the Great
Plains states these views extend to
Social and cultural questions as well
and I think it's fine for states that
have very different approaches to the
way their citizens want to live it's not
fine when some of these left-wing States
try to then begin imposing those views
and those values on more conservative
areas of the country yeah I think that's
the great challenge we have going
forward is that a certain set of people
are going to want to be left alone and a
certain set of people won't want them to
leave alone and and I don't know how you
how you Arbitrage those two things what
what just away from the book for just a
moment what would you want people to
know about Arkansas that maybe they
don't know you know we we talk a lot
about Cali now we talk about Florida or
New York or some of the bigger States or
Coastal States we don't talk about
Arkansas that much what should people
know about Arkansas
Arkansas is a great beautiful State uh
with wonderful people you know if you
don't like so much heat and humidity in
the Summers you get in Florida you
should come to Arkansas where we have
four beautiful seasons
um there's a lot of opportunity all
across the state a real Rich diversity
uh across the state you know in eastern
Arkansas we have some of the most
fertile Farmland in the country South
and West Arkansas has some of the great
uh Timber forests that we have across
the country beautiful mountains both the
Ozarks and the ouachita's especially in
Northwest Arkansas there's rapidly
growing economy that has about a
thousand people moving in every month so
there's just a lot of rich and rewarding
reasons to move to Arkansas or at least
come and try it out for a visit uh
there's no bad time to come to Arkansas
we welcome you up there Dave just like
we'd welcome a lot of your California
refugees coming in as well as long as
they don't bring their politics with
them
that seems to be the key to the entire
thing I basically have to walk around
here with a DeSantis hat to make sure
that my neighbors aren't freaking out
about me uh Senator I appreciate your
time the book Is Only the Strong we'll
link to it right down below uh and I'm
gonna be in DC a little bit after the
election doing some live interviews so I
have a feeling you'll be in a good mood
for a couple days after that so if
you're in DC maybe we can connect then
thanks Dave swing by uh in between your
meeting with all the large number of new
Republican Senators and congressmen
sounds like a plan Senator Tom Cotton
thank you very much
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell